bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
nessuno video sono parigi oggi siamo
tornati con un revival pazzesco
non so se vi ricordate italia francia
solo che click on the picture of the
monna lisa è poi caduto perché ha preso
una testata la testata gliel'ha data
gina l'intera di zidane i ragazzi spero
vi ricordiate con la partita abbiamo
fatto un revival non contro i francesi
ma contro l'inghilterra
insomma questa è stata la partita buona
visione ragazzi america america le erika
o inglese il terre delle diverse non
sono inglesi sono in inglese testa
all'inghilterra milan oggi abbiamo
italia inghilterra o in italia di terra
madonna o quasi gol subito un 2 3 a
talora ragazzi stiamo facendo un media e
valeva di italia francia 3 se però non
possono anche fare l'intro che ansia
come abbiamo fatto fuori la francia
abbiamo far fuori l'inghilterra si
potranno avere il tè migliore ma noi
abbiamo l'estate
oggi no ragazzi che quest ultimo
bellissimo e tdt estate is our kakà
chiude un termine anche loro sanno il
bidet se possiamo aggiungere la verona
richiamare sul celibato pazzesco come
fatto a prendere paolini critica vacca
pro mattina è ferrero isa italian sul
nejm ragazzini primo la rivistazione che
cosa vi ho messo
guardi bellissima 2 a 0
ieri il terra quando serve mamma mia
we have the video we don't have the
monnalisa ietf a dei francesi will give
it to hours and you still don del david
e quindi diciamo mamma mia non ho visto
cosa hai fatto ciccio guarda però questo
è per te prendi questo e inghilterra a
madonna che tiro è fatto non ho neanche
visto perchè stavo in porto perché no no
viene fuori una volta lo stesso sopra
non l'ho tolta su dentro e così via
mio dio fosse riuscito a togliere questa
per miracolo divino successo liber
cortile questa falsa pena ma avete avuto
una sfiga tremenda è passata in mezzo io
sento e non pareggiano pro ragazzi hanno
messo venti secondi e far bene ragazzi
che mi date il cervello per cortesia
rifacciamo il video
bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo non si può fare che c'è il timer
madonna che tiro fatto l'esame grazie al
bellissimo brano cc batte le punizioni
ciccio quando lo fai le cappellate fai
queste cose ho visti pochi tutti noi ciò
non è così si legga quanto vi fate
sudare ma io veramente god
sì c'è un macchina tiri ma sono stati
capaci di scusarsi scusate scusate la
ragione cosa scusate ma ti rendi conto
scusate posso solo dirvi
mi sono confuso city con colori aspetta
aspetta aspetta da sole non è che
ragazzino vi prego ma scusatemi come
questo se trasformati ronaldinho trova
qua abbiamo un minuto fammi un gol
almeno la loro porta però dio santo
no ragazzi fanno 541 recuperiamo più ve
lo dico non so come siamo poi no no mio
dio che non si stano pure togliendo la
gara per favore se mia io non ho ancora
fatto un gol sarebbe ottimo aveva fatto
20 assist ma zero gol che mise a segno
io non è male però magari non così raga
toglietela l'altro dietro un bravissimo
veniamo in avanti come ho fatto un
casino
la butta fuori mezzo ragazzi non è vero
scherzo the picture of the state
il bayern abbiamo segnato ho insegnato
se non me l'hai chiamata brosco novembre
avere ragione stavo di urlando di mina
tenzione profit produca pirlo può
inventare che supplementari sempre
supplementari abbiamo figli nei video di
rocket ma com'è possibile
l'ho tolta l'ho tolta l'ho tolta
perfetto volo ragazzi occhio la vola
vola vola vola l'ape maia ha volato
storto ma edizione volato storto volato
solo ha distrutto cc portaci ci importa
cori velocità marzo minacce a ciccio
l'esercizio colori e da macho ciccio per
tutto il video oppure basta un signore e
in mezzo la tiro io giravo le parate
scusami scusami scusami scusami no non
entrava comunque entrava figlia di pochi
occhio la butta in mezzo ragazzi anzi la
controllo maledizione se quello non
c'era tocca a tutti e mezzo di nuovo
bella la toccata alla butto di nuovo in
mezzo non riesco raga occhio che
ripartono vi prego di perote queste va
male ciccio questa fama le toglie la
bravo la tiro io
che scarso
[Applauso]
d'estate is better than the english
breakfast remember ragazzi ci siamo ci
sono scusate perché lo spaccato tutto
ciò che stavo dicendo che comunque noi
non possiamo fare ogni volta non lo
possiamo fare la partita tranquilla una
volta vi prego rassegnata ci incontriamo
e faceva partita tranquilla che non può
infatti su yo yo broni taranto basilisco
non va bene
ho perso per kg fatti io c'ho vostra
fidanzata ma va bene che imbarazzanti
comunque va bene se la partita ragazza
ragazzi soprattutto a ciccio per gli
infarti gratuiti perché verrebbero ci
mette un po di peperoncino capito mesi
di peperoncino allevamenti e andare in
inghilterra che non c'erano il b day per
pulire mi raccomando
[Musica]